what this does is it basically  transforms Thor into the god of gods  because we now have Thor wielding the  all-black necro sword a weapon designed  to do nothing more than kill gods and  Destroy worlds as well as wielding two  hammers this is probably the single  greatest picture that I've ever seen in  my life when it comes to Thor he looks  so badass with this with his whole his  whole get up he's just like cloud and  black with two hammers I mean it's one  of the coolest things that I've ever  seen but but uh Gore has essentially  lost the source of his power that's  really what it is he has no power left  there's nothing left coming to him he is  effectively as mortal as he was in his  origin story